ah enfin
la porte s'ouvre devant nous la depuis
2004 elle était fermée
16 ans qu'alain mot rêve attendait ce
moment
la réouverture de la porte de l'église
de sa commune
tout un symbole et même une victoire
déclaré en péril en 2004 l'édifice
religieux était jusqu alors fermée au
public
un crève coeur pour les habitants du
bourg suite à un courrier de monsieur le
curé qui voyait les pères qui était
profond et a6 et a10 faut faire quelque
chose
c'est un choc d'une violence inouïe on
ferme une église c'était très mal pris
par la population une fermeture
nécessaire du aux outrages du temps
sacristie façades toitures c'est toute
la structure de cette église du 11e
siècle qu'il a fallu renforcer quand on
a pris ce chantier effectivement nous
avons trouvé une charpente qui était
très très très abîmés voire même à des
endroits complètement pourri et donc
une grosse intervention était nécessaire
pour au niveau des charpentes qui ont
été refaites à l'identique
un chantier titanesque de 600000 euros
financé aux trois quarts par le loto du
patrimoine une aide exceptionnelle pour
la petite commune c'était une bonne
heure c'est dire enfin on va pouvoir
réparer cette église à moindre frais à
quoi c'était inespéré mais il espérait
on peut le dire le mot inespéré et on a
eu l'impression qu'on a été aidé par le
ciel un cadeau du ciel
un cadeau du ciel alors exactement aux
prochaines étapes des travaux à
l'intérieur de l'église ainsi que son
clocher la mairie a d'ores et déjà lancé
un appel aux dons
[Musique]